je veux être enterré orvilliers je ne
veux ni fleurs ni couronnes ni monuments
funéraires bien sûr une simple dalle de
pierre de taille avec mon nom et la date
de ma naissance et de ma mort une messe
sera dite à paris à saint louis en l'île
elle sera chantée en grégorien signée
georges pompidou août 1972
telles sont les dernières volontés du
président de la république georges
pompidou écrite de sa main
il y a un an et demi après s'être rendu
4 et une housse repose la dépouille
mortelle de monsieur pompidou après
avoir réuni à l'hôtel matignon son
gouvernement conseil de cabinet et après
en avoir informé monsieur alain poher
qui assure l'intérim de la présidence de
la république monsieur pierre messmer a
fait publier un communiqué indiquant
respectant la volonté du président
georges pompidou et à la demande de sa
famille une messe sera célébrée jeudi 4
avril à 11 heures en l'église saint
louis en l'île
la famille les membres du gouvernement
et les collaborateurs proches du
président assisteront seul à cette
cérémonie de caractère privé
l'inhumation aura lieu à orvilliers dans
la stricte intimité familiale
cette journée prendra un caractère de
recueillement national auquel le
gouvernement invite les français à
s'associer
deuxièmement une cérémonie solennelle
d'hommage au président georges pompidou
aura lieu le samedi 6 avril à 11 heures
à la cathédrale notre dame de paris en
présence des membres du gouvernement du
parlement des corps constitués et des
délégations étrangères
cette journée sera une journée de deuil
national
les administrations les établissements
d'enseignement seront fermés aucun
spectacle ne sera donnée troisièmement
pour former mentale usage tous les
drapeaux seront mis en berne jusqu'à la
fin du mois
un registre est ouvert au palais de
l'elysée destinée à recueillir les
témoignages des france
et des françaises quatrièmement le
conseil des ministres se réunira le
vendredi 5 avril au palais de l'elysée
ce conseil des ministres donc sera
présidée par monsieur alain poher
monsieur roger frey avait réuni vers
midi le conseil constitutionnel peu
après il donnait lui même lecture du
communiqué publié par le conseil
constitutionnel
je vais vous donner lecture de la
déclaration du conseil constitutionnel
le conseil constitutionnel constate à la
suite du décès le 2 avril 1974
21h02 monsieur georges pompidou
président de la république que sont
réunies les conditions prévues à
l'article 7 de la constitution relatives
à l'exercice provisoire des fonctions du
président de la république par le
président du sénat il déclare que
s'ouvre à partir de cette date le délai
fixé par ce même article pour l'élection
du nouveau président de la république
la présente déclaration sera publié au
journal officiel de la république
française
délibéré par le conseil constitutionnel
dans sa séance du 3 avril 1974
en ouvrant la séance les prononcer
l'allocution suivante messieurs le
président de la république est mort je
ne dirai rien à cette heure des
sentiments personnels que j'éprouve un
sentiment qui me seraient dictés avant
tout par la peine profonde de perdre un
ami très cher acquis tant de souvenirs
me liés mais le président du conseil
constitutionnel à l'impérieux devoir de
rendre au chef de l'état qui vient de
disparaître
le vibrant hommage qui lui est dû sans
rien trahir du dernier entretien que
j'ai eu l'honneur d'avoir avec lui je
voudrais dire que sa préoccupation
dominante était celle de la france et de
son destin
c'est à elle
et aux français calais toutes ses
pensées
c'est pour elle et pour eux il fit
preuve jusqu'au dernier jour d'une
volonté et d'un courage qui force
l'admiration et qui le rendent à jamais
digne d'avoir été le premier des
français
j'exprime à madame georges pompidou à
ses enfants à sa famille notre profonde
émotion et je leur présente les
condoléances respectueuse et très
attristé qui conseil constitutionnel
l'émotion dont parlait monsieur frais et
celle de tous les français surpris par
la nouvelle brutale annoncée hier soir
par un bref communiqué signé du
professeur vignalou et annonçant à 22
heures que le président de la république
était décédée à 21h on savait monsieur
pompidou malades ou pressentait la
gravité du mal sans savoir quelle il
était mais son courage qu'il a fait
rester jusqu'à la dernière minute à la
tête du pays pour assumer ses
responsabilités courage salué
unanimement france et à l'étranger
ce courage était telle qu'on ne pouvait
imaginer une issue tragique
si rapide dès que la mort de monsieur
pompidou fut rendu public des centaines
de parisiens se massaient devant le
palais de l'elysée où kate béthune tard
dans la nuit deux fenêtres allumées au
second étage
c'est ici que le président georges
pompidou est mort au terme d'une
souffrance qu'il avait su cacher avant
de sombrer dans le coma hier en fin
d'après midi
il ne s'était pas écoulée une demi heure
après l annonce du décès que déjà des
centaines de personnes se pressaient
quête béthune derrière ces barrières
installées à la hâte par les policiers
des visages émus et parfois stupéfait
pour respecter le deuil de madame
pompidou de son fils docteur alain
pompidou
la rue avait été interdite à la
circulation puis à l'aube après la pluie
un silence impressionnant entouré cet
appartement qui est est encore plus que
la maison d'orvilliers le vrai refuge de
monsieur et de madame pompidou
ici seuls entrait les amis intimes
le chef de l'état repose maintenant sur
son lit de mort près du salon
bibliothèque tandis que des ouvriers
installent à l'entrée du numéro 24 des
tentures funéraire
il y avait autant de monde cette nuit
devant le palais de l'elysée les mêmes
visages attristé des gens qui attendent
on le sait quoi ce qu'ils ont vu ça les
aura peut être étonné car déjà en pleine
nuit on venait récupérer les dossiers
les archives personnelles du président
pompidou
c'est pourtant l'usa
oui et non
comme celle usage aussi les plus proches
collaborateurs du président pompidou qui
se sont encore réunies ce matin
proposeront de présenter leur démission
émotion tout aussi intense dans le petit
village d'orvilliers près de paris où le
chef de l'état et met à se reposer dans
sa maison blanche c'est également ici
que voter georges pompidou écouter le
maire d'orvilliers je suis rempli
chagrin comme tous les français envers
le grand français qui était en même
temps citoyens d'orvilliers c'est
assurer ses fonctions avec un courage
exemplaire jusqu'au 7 à khazar sur les
bords du lot qu'avant d'être président
de la république georges pompidou avait
été élu conseiller municipal il avait
refusé d'être maire de quasar car
disent-ils
ceux qui travaillent ici doivent en
assumer les fonctions georges pompidou
georges pompidou était alors premier
ministre je garde un souvenir vraiment
très amicale
car monsieur pompidou est d'être un
homme affable servia toujours prêt à
rendre service et devait de bons
conseils généraux supérieurs comme il a
très peu en france
notre pays car le l'autre de la france
dès son départ si subi dans le cantal
enfin voici montboudif son village natal
les parents de georges pompidou sont
enterrés ici
le président ne reposera pas auprès
d'eux comme vous le savez c'est la terre
d'orvilliers qu'ivey qui le recueillera
loin de là mais si près de sa maison
blanche qu'il aimait tant
il n'y a pas eu de passants aujourd'hui
kate béthune dans l'île saint louis
qu'il convient de respecter l'intimité
la famille de monsieur pompidou qui
veille sa dépouille mortelle
cependant de chaque côté des barrières
des parisiens ému et silencieux en
direct du quai de béthune françois
bonnin une deuxième nuit de veille
commence au deuxième étage du 24 rue de
béthune vous propose depuis hier soir à
son domicile
georges pompidou depuis une heure les
volets des fenêtres de l'appartement du
chef de l'état ont été baissés la
dernière personnalité qui est venu
s'incliner devant la dépouille mortelle
du président de la république et
s'entretenir avec madame pompidou fut le
cardinal marty archevêque de paris
arrivé à 17 heures il quittait le quai
de béthune 25 minutes plus tard avec
pierre messmer arrivé ce matin à 9
heures ce sont les deux seules
personnalités officielles à s'être rendu
aujourd'hui au domicile de georges
pompidou
en cela la volonté du défunt et de
madame pompidou a été respectée tout au
long de cette journée vous le disiez
michel péricard plusieurs centaines de
personnes sont venues rendre un hommage
silencieux au chef de l'état sur les
deux ponts qui encadrent le quai de
béthune les parisiens s'arrête un
instant ce recueil interroge les
journalistes sur les cérémonies de
demain puis repartent discrètement sur
le quai toujours interdite surveillé par
un petit cordon de policiers seuls les
riverains les amis et la famille du
président de la république peuvent
passer ainsi que les nombreuses
camionnettes qui ne cessèrent de déposer
des fleurs et des tv g
dans le milieu de l'après-midi quelques
instants avant l'arrivée de monseigneur
marty le cercueil dans lequel repose
maintenant le président georges pompidou
fut apportée ont vite également un
officier de police
porteur d'un drapeau tricolore plier
franchir la lourde porte de bois du 24
quai de béthune c'est dans louis saint
denis
c'est dans l'île saint-louis pardon ce
village au coeur de paris très appréciée
de georges pompidou que se dérouleront
demain à 11 heures les obsèques
religieuses du président depuis 19h plus
aucune voiture n'est autorisé à
stationner dans les rues avoisinant le
domicile de georges pompidou à 11 heures
le cercueil du président de la
république franchira la centaine de
mètres qui séparent son domicile de la
très belle église de saint louis en île
située juste derrière l'immeuble la
messe chantée en grégorien à la demande
du chef de l'etat sera célébrée par le
chanoine barbotin qui maria le fils du
président et de madame pompidou et
baptisa ses petits-enfants
monsieur messmer reste premier ministre
et son gouvernement en place jusqu'à la
prochaine élection présidentielle
au milieu de la nuit dans une allocution
radiodiffusée
monsieur messmer après avoir adressé
mâcon pidoux à ses enfants ses
sentiments émues et attristées avait
déclaré nous salue avec respect le
courage d'un homme qui malgré sa maladie
et jusqu'à la veille de sa mort
assumez en pleine lucidité son devoir de
chef de l'état que le civisme de tous
répondent à ce qui aurait été son
attente le gouvernement et moi-même dans
le respect de la constitution de la
république n'y manqueront pas en direct
de la cour de l'hôtel matignon
alain ferme bac
après midi calmes après midi silencieuse
ici à l'hôtel matignon le premier
ministre est resté dans son bureau
peu de visiteurs en début d'après midi
hubert germain et jean taittinger
avec eux il a préparé la déclaration
qu'il fera demain au parlement pour
rendre hommage au président de la
république
d'autres ministres ou anciens ministres
sont venus mais extrêmement discrètement
comme monsieur michel debré monsieur
jacques chirac est tout à l'heure aussi
monsieur frêle le nouveau président du
conseil constitutionnel mais est ce
matin que monsieur messmer a présidé un
conseil de cabinet exactement comme en
1969 après la démission du général de
gaulle
monsieur goût de murville avait présidé
un conseil de cabinet ce conseil de
cabine est extrêmement court
20 minutes vous connaissez maintenant il
a été donné au début de journal le
communiqué qui a été publié
à son issue mais regardons les images la
sortie du conseil de cabinet monsieur
messmer partira le premier quart
est allé voir le président du sénat
monsieur alain poher qui est devenu
président de la république par intérim
regarder le visage de ces sommes tous
encore était mercredi dernier à la table
du conseil des ministres à l'elysée
autour du président de la république sur
les visages de tous ces mini ce la peine
le chagrin aucun de le dissimuler
monsieur alain poher n'a pas quitté la
présidence du sénat au palais du
luxembourg par déférence pour le deuil
de la famille de monsieur pompidou
monsieur power ne s'installera l'elysée
qu après les obsèques vendredi matin
cette nuit dès qu'il fut informé par le
secrétaire général de l'elysée monsieur
balladur du décès de monsieur pompidou
monsieur prière avait déclaré qu'il
s'inclinait devant la douleur de la
famille et qu'il était bouleversé par la
nouvelle et monsieur power ajoutait le
courage et le dévouement du chef de
l'état au cours des mois écoulés force
mon admiration
ainsi que celle de toutes les françaises
et de tous les français que j'invite à
s'inspirer d'un aussi hot exemple en
direct du palais du luxembourg
claude revelli je peux tout d'abord vous
confirmer officiellement que monsieur
alain poher le président de la
république par intérim s'adressera aux
français
demain à 20 heures dans une allocution
télévisée une allocution qui sera
enregistré demain dans l'après-midi
dissident le bureau de monsieur poher
ici au sénat la nuit est tombée une nuit
qui a apporté un grand calme après une
légère effervescence dans la journée
puisque beaucoup de voitures officielles
ont fait le va et vient ici au sénat
mais maintenant il n'y a plus une seule
voiture officielle devant le bureau de
monsieur paul hertz a d'abord été ce
matin monsieur permet ce maire venu
informer monsieur poher du conseil de
cabinet qui s'était tenue à l'hôtel
matignon
dans l'après midi monsieur la can mais
le président du centre démocrate qui est
venue à son initiative rendre visite à
monsieur alain poher et puis monsieur
roger frey le président du conseil
constitutionnel qui est venu ici au
sénat à la demande de monsieur alain
poher vous voyez d'ailleurs n'est de
voir quelques images très furtive de la
sortie de monsieur roger frais lorsqu'il
a quitté monsieur power je peux vous
dire que le président de la république
par intérim a reçu plusieurs sénateurs
également dans l'après-midi et qu'il a
eu beaucoup m'a-t-on dit beaucoup de
contacts téléphoniques avec un certain
nombre d'hommes politiques
c'est donc michel péricard le disais à
l'instant vendredi à 9h30 que monsieur
power entrera à l'elysée pour présider
le conseil des ministres
il recevra demain ici donc dans son
bureau du sénat
à 11 heures monsieur edgar faure le
président de l'assemblée nationale
voilà ce que l'on peut dire pour la
journée ici au sénat la journée de
monsieur alain poher je vous propose
d'ailleurs maintenant de voir un film
retraçant quelques aspects de la vie de
monsieur alain poret vendredi matin pour
la seconde fois en moins de cinq ans
monsieur alain poher entrera l'elysée
pour assurer l'intérim de la présidence
de la république le 28 avril 1969
le président du sénat avait alors durant
46 jours assumer cette lourde charge
c'était après l'échec subi par le
général de gaulle au référendum sur la
régionalisation et sa démission le 27
avril à minuit monsieur alain poher aura
65 ans dans 15 jours
il est né à ablon sur seine petite
localité de la banlieue parisienne le 17
avril 1902 il est marié et père d'un
enfant il est licencié en droit diplômé
de l'école des sciences politiques
en 1946 il sera chef de cabinet de
monsieur robert schuman alors ministre
des finances cette rencontre marquera sa
vie et on fera un fervent partisan de
l'europe et c'est à travers les
organismes européens qu'il se fera
connaître au parlement européen où en
1966 il sera élu président et fait
unique dans l'histoire de cette
assemblée
réélu durant trois années consécutives
en 1968 il quitte une présidence pour
une autre celle du sénat où le 2 octobre
il est élu à la majorité absolue il sera
réélu en 1971 et c'est à ce titre de
président du sénat qu'il devra d'assumer
l'intérim de 1969 pas les lidd il sera
en même temps candidat du centre contre
georges pompidou pour les
présidentielles il sera second premier
tour avec 23% des suffrages
depuis si monsieur alain poher et peu
intervenu dans la vie politique tout en
maintenant ses liens avec les centristes
d'opposition
il a par contre activement participé à
une normalisation des relations entre le
sénat et le régime ses rapports avec les
gaullistes ont évolué mais ses
conceptions européenne l'opposent
toujours à la majorité son caractère
conciliant son souci des relations
humaines lui permettront
d'assumer cet intérim et de présider le
conseil des ministres dans un esprit de
sérénité
toute la presse française a publié des
éditions spéciales sur la mort de
monsieur pompidou les radios comme la
télévision diffuse aussi depuis hier
soir 22h des programmes spéciaux
l'émotion est la même partout et le mot
qui revient le plus souvent dans les
titres de nos confrères ou dans les
conversations privées et le mot courage
ce courage du président de la république
jusqu'à ses derniers instants qui
suscite l'admiration de tout ce qui fait
écrire à plusieurs de nos confrères que
monsieur pompidou est mort debout dans
les réactions des hommes politiques
français c'est la même unanimité le
courage du président jusqu'à ses
derniers instants
provoc l'estiment et fort sa narration
une majorité de françaises et de
français a permis à georges pompidou de
continuer l'oeuvre de redressement
entreprises par la vème république
en ces heures tragiques ou la
disparition brutale du chef de l'état et
me les français et ajoutent aux graves
périls de l'air
l'intérêt national commande le maintien
et l'extension de ce grand rassemblement
qui a tant fait pour la france depuis 16
la disparition du président de la
république et je crois profondément
ressentie par tous les français
il avait appris à estimer à aimer ce
président qui était si profondément en
français dans lequel chacun d'entre eux
se retrouver un petit peu chez lequel il
retrouvait ses qualités le mesure de bon
sens d' équilibre qui sont les qualités
ancestrale fondamental de la france et
républicains indépendants appartenait à
sa majorité présidentielle ils lui ont
constamment apporté un appui fidèle et
il s'incline aujourd'hui devant
la dignité le courage de celui qui a su
assumer la direction de la france
jusqu'au bout de ses forces
je voudrais dire aussi combien notre
admiration pas au courage du président
pompidou ce courage nous le sentions à
l'action tous les jours et nous ne
pensions pas qu'il allait aussi loin
dans le dévouement dans le sens du
service et puis je dirais que nous
centristes
nous avons une raison particulière
encore d'être touchés bouleversés par
cette mort brillant pompidou c'était
l'homme de l'ouverture de l'ouverture en
france de l'ouverture en europe de
l'ouverture dans le monde
c'était aussi correspondant à notre
idéal social un homme préoccupé de la
vie quotidienne des français avec un
sens très humains de leurs problèmes et
je crois que tout cela nous avait
attaché à sa personne profondément comme
tout le monde je suis encore sous le
coup de cet événement inattendu et
dramatique sur le plan personnel comme
sur le plan national
sur le plan personnel tout le monde l'a
dit c'est un drame humain émouvant
extraordinaire qui prend fin
tragiquement
nous comprenons maintenant l'énergie le
courage avec lesquels à travers la
maladie et les souffrances
le président de la république a
jusqu'aux derniers jours fait face à ses
responsabilités il remplit sa mission
sur le plan national
notre pays se trouve placé en quelque
sorte du jour au lendemain
face au problème capital de la
continuité du pouvoir de l'état de la
nation en même temps que devant les
choix politiques fondamentaux
bien sûr nos institutions prévoient les
procédures
ur et les délais mais tous les problèmes
de fond sont posées et c'est vraiment
notre avenir à tous qui dépend des
réponses qui leur seront apportées
l'heure n'est pas à mon sens aux
querelles personnelles ni aux polémiques
partisanes et je suis sûr que chacun
d'entre nous on prendra les
responsabilités qui sont les siennes
après l'événement tragique dont tous
ensemble nous portons le deuil tous les
français quelles que soient leurs
opinions ressentent la disparition du
président de la république comme une
peine qui est à chacun particulière nous
saluons le courage d'un homme qui assume
et ses lourdes responsabilités jusqu'à
l'extrême limite des forces humaines la
france maintenant et devant un événement
de grande ampleur
un événement d'autant plus lourd que la
france et l'europe traverse une crise
mais je suis convaincu que cette fois
encore les français surmonteront
l'épreuve
ils garderont le calme
ils aimeront l'ordre et ils
s'efforceront au delà du drame
bouleversant de ce jour de regarder leur
avenir
je dois donc dire vous même et au pays
que j'éprouve un sentiment de compassion
devant la rigueur du destin qui frappe
georges pompidou est devant la peine de
sa famille de ses proches et de ses amis
le président de la république est mort
en restant fidèle à lui-même et à sa
conception du devoir il est important
qu'un homme public offre à son pays
cette valeur d'exemple il sera temps
demain de reprendre le combat politique
chacun à sa façon et de tirer la leçon
de 12 ans de gouvernement mais
aujourd'hui il convient de se recueillir
et de réfléchir à ce qui sera bon pour
la france adversaire
la politique de georges pompidou
nous nous inclinons devant l'homme qui
vient de succomber à la maladie après un
dur et courageux combat
la disparition subite du président de la
république alors que notre pays connaît
une crise profonde pose à celui ci de
façon précipitée la question du choix de
son avenir
le peuple français en décidera dans le
calme et la dignité dans le cadre des
règles constitutionnelles en vigueur à
l'étranger
l'émotion et la consternation ne sont
pas moindres qu'en france il n'est pas
de capital qui n'ait exprimé ses
sentiments parfois en décrétant un deuil
national comme en république
centrafricaine en anglais en argentine
ou au brésil à tunis par exemple en ce
moment même le président bourguiba
adresse un message télévisé à son peuple
déjà plusieurs chefs d'état ou de
gouvernement fait connaître leur
intention d'être présents samedi à notre
dame de paris on indiquait ainsi tout à
l'heure à washington que la présence du
président nixon était hautement probable
de même est annoncée celle du chancelier
brand celle du roi baudouin
celle du président de la haute volta et
du président de et du premier ministre
pardon canadien monsieur trudeau ainsi
que du premier ministre du québec
monsieur
huras a ainsi que du premier ministre du
japon
monsieur tanaka pour mieux comprendre ce
que ressent dans ce moment les capitales
étrangères
nous allons appeler successivement
quelques-unes d'entre elles confient
double était considéré à bonn comme un
ami et un partenaire loyal
sa mort est considérée comme une perte
autant pour la france que pour l'europe
ce matin le gouvernement allemand a donc
rendu un hommage solennel au président
confie du devant tous ces ministres vie
libre en en personne à lui l'hommage de
son pays au président pompidou la mort
du président français a déclenché chez
nous et dans le monde entier une
profonde émotion
j'exprime au peuple français notre
voisin notre compassion a dit vie lebron
qui a aussi insisté sur le rôle de
georges pompidou dans le processus
d'union européenne
le président pompidou est mort à la
tâche le courage exceptionnel avec
lequel il accomplit sa mission jusqu'à
la dernière minute lui vaut aujourd'hui
l'estiment et la considération de tous
les européens
georges pompidou restera pour eux
l'héritier du général de gaulle et dans
la lutte qui va s'engager pour la
succession
les européens y voit une phase
déterminante pour la démocratie
française de grands dessins ont guidé
son action
il a tenu à réaffirmer l'indépendance de
la france son rôle dans le monde
de même il a su inspirer à ses
partenaires une relance de la
construction européenne rendre la france
à l'europe
leur vraie place dans le monde telle fut
la mission qu'il s'est donnée
d'accomplir grâce à son impulsion au
sommet de la et de paris et de
copenhague il a voulu à signer les
objectifs de l'europe comme union
économique et monétaire
revitaliser la coopération politique
jusqu'à la dernière minute leur a lutté
pour que les nefs dégage une identité de
vues européennes qui soit un exemple
pour les autres nations du monde quelle
sera la politique européenne de la
france de demain
en attendant sa pensée ici dans les
milieux européens que paris désormais
fera preuve de moins de fermeté
l'après gaullisme de l'europe vient de
commencer tous les drapeaux sont en
berne aujourd'hui à londres
qu'ils soient anglais ou français la
grande bretagne elle aussi porte le
deuil après la disparition du président
georges pompidou à la consternation et à
l'affliction succès de ce soir une
sourde inquiétude
que va-t-il se passer en france que va
devenir l'europe
edward heath l'ancien premier ministre
nous a fait part de son émotion la mort
du président pompidou est une grande
perte pour la france pour l'amitié
franco-anglaise pour la communauté
européenne
en un mot pour l'europe entière et le
monde atlantique
je le connaissais bien et ce depuis 12
ans nous avons travaillé très
étroitement ensemble lors des
négociations pour l'admission de la
grande-bretagne marché comme je l'aimais
je l'admirais et le respecter on
s'entendait bien
le pape a aussi rendu hommage
aujourd'hui pour président pompidou et
nous voulons exprimer notre
participation au deuil national que hier
soir a frappé la france bat la mort
imprévue du président pompidou personnel
de tout premier ordre tant nous mais
nous avons eu l'occasion de recevoir la
visite d'un gène audience spéciale et de
reconnaître aux qualités de sagesse et
de courtoisie à rome et alors que tous
les drapeaux sont en berne sur les
bâtiments officiels
les journaux s'interrogent sur l'avenir
de la france et de l'europe
puis la france donnait un nouveau guide
sur les sages qui continuera d'assurer
la grandeur de la france et de l'europe
c'est le voeu exprimé par la stampa le
corriere della serra constate que la
mort du président pompidou survient à un
moment particulièrement difficile pour
l'europe de l'extrême droite à l'extrême
gauche tout le monde en tout cas parle
du courage du président pompidou qui
assumer sa tâche jusqu'à la fin
à l'occasion de mes rencontres avec
georges pompidou fait connu un homme
d'une grande perspicacité modérée est
tenace et d'une immense force de
caractère
la france a perdu l'un de ses grands
dirigeants le monde a perdu un grand
homme d'état
telles sont quelques-unes des paroles
ému et chaleureuse prononcé hier soir
par le président nixon et le
vice-président fort de cet état
kissinger edward kennedy la plupart des
dirigeants républicains et démocrates se
sont joints à cet hommage
car malgré la période difficile que
traversent les rapports franco américain
en ce moment georges pompidou reste pour
les états unis
l'homme de la réconciliation de l'amitié
retrouvée après avoir rendu visite au
général de gaulle en 1969 le président
nixon avait rencontré pompidou à quatre
reprises et les deux hommes avaient su
établir entre eux des rapports confiance
des amicaux la brusque disparition de
l'homme d'état français a surpris les
américains les journaux du matin ont
consacré leurs gros titres à l'événement
plusieurs milliers de personnes sont
déjà venues signer les registres de
condoléances ouvert dans les ambassades
et les consulats de france
il se trouve que cette semaine plusieurs
hebdomadaires avaient publié deux longs
reportages relatifs à l'état de santé de
georges pompidou
mais personne ne pouvait imaginer ici
une fin aussi brutale
l'agent stas dans son premier
commentaire sur la nouvelle situation
créée en france après la disparition
subite du président pompidou souligner
l'importance de la contribution apportée
par le président défunt à la continuité
de la politique du général de gaulle
évoquant les récents entretiens de
picsou d'un l'agent soviétique appel ce
soir que les deux dirigeants s'étaient
déclarés satisfaits de l'état des
relations franco soviétique qui avait
préconisé le développement et
l'approfondissement ultérieure de la
coopération entre les deux pays
ce même espoir est exprimée dans le
message de condoléances adressé ce matin
par les dirigeants du kremlin à
messieurs alain poher et pierre messmer
comme on le voit le kremlin restent
anxieux quant au destin ultérieure des
rapports franco soviétique
cette inquiétude ne se dissipera pas
avant plusieurs mois
d'ici là on doit attendre de la part des
russes une longue période de déficit ce
calcul
monsieur léopold senghor président de la
république du sénégal étaient des amis
de longue date ils avaient fait leurs
études ensemble à paris voici ce que
monsieur senghor a déclaré ce matin à
dakar en apprenant la mort de son ami
georges pompidou
vous prendrez une foire pénible de
parler aujourd'hui de la mort du
président georges pompidou
en effet il tue un ami de 45 ans je les
ai rencontrés pour la première fois au
lycée louis-le-grand en une fin 29 et
depuis que pendant quarante-cinq années
notre amitié est restée la même
solide malgré toutes les épreuves
traversées
notre entrée dans la politique aurait pu
affaiblir cette amitié est là à
renforcer nos planifier le fait
simplement pour un fils y voit les deux
tweeters six chefs d'état chefs de
gouvernement ministres les affaires
étrangères ou ambassadeurs
représenteront samedi à notre-dame à 11
heures la terre entière sait vous le
savez dans la plus stricte intimité que
se dérouleront demain les obsèques de
monsieur georges pompidou ni public ni
journaliste
mais dès ce soir à l'initiative du curé
de l'église de la madeleine
la paroisse du dépend le palais de
l'elysée une messe était célébrée à la
mémoire de monsieur pompidor la paroisse
qui couvre le palais de l'elysée a
décidé
de célébrer spontanément une messe à la
mémoire du président pompidou à cette
peste à 6 de la foule anonyme de
parisiens qui sont venus nombreux très
nombreux avant même que la messe ne
commence l'église est bondé ceux qui
veulent ainsi rendre hommage au
président défunt sorte pour beaucoup de
leur travail sortent des bureaux
il ya là beaucoup de ménagères avec
leurs sacs de courses découpe des jeunes
beaucoup de jeunes et des vieux aussi
bref un défilé en raccourci du peuple de
france qui avait choisi georges pompidou
pour président la république il ya près
de six ans
on se demande quelle image quels traits
caractéristiques de la personnalité de
georges pompidou ses citoyens anonymes
et finalement mystérieux ont-ils présent
à l'esprit du président défunt l'un aura
plus spécialement une vision de sa
bonhomie par exemple l'autre de son
autorité ou le souvenir de son rôle dans
les événements de mai 68 ou bien celui
de ses expressions physiques ou verbales
sur le petit écran et d'autres encore
déjà individuellement chacun de ses
esprits dessine à grands traits l'image
de celui qui désormais appartient à
l'histoire
les réflexions les discussions des
bavardages des uns et des autres les
analyses les synthèses de l'action et la
personnalité du président les écrits et
les dires de bouche à oreille commence
d'ores et déjà à former l'image
populaire que l'histoire retiendra de
georges pompidou
ces déplacements des citoyens parisiens
les réactions des capitales étrangères
que nous avons entendu comme les
réactions si nombreuse qui se sont
élevées de partout en france montre
assez la place que tenait monsieur
pompidou et l'importance du rôle du
président dans les institutions de la
vème république
c'est dire qu'il est difficile d'ignorer
les interrogations que pose la
disparition du chef de l'état même si
pour des raisons faciles à comprendre
nulle prise de position n'interviendra
avant la célébration des obsèques
joseph poli il n'est pas facile
il est même pénible quelques heures
après la mort du président de parler
déjà de politique et de succession mais
comment ne pas évoquer ce soir
brièvement le grand vide le grand vide
constitutionnel
créé par la disparition de georges
pompidou le premier conseil des ministre
présidera alain poher vendredi matin à
10h fixera les conditions du deuil
national comme il ne serait pas
convenable de parler à la fois du deuil
national et de la date de la prochaine
élection présidentielle
c'est vraisemblablement un autre conseil
des ministres très proches qui fixera la
date de cette élection
la constitution est parfaitement clair à
ce sujet l'élection a lieu fin jours au
moins et 35 jours au plus après
l'ouverture de la vacance dans ces
conditions seul pour le premier tour
deux dates sont possibles dimanche 28
avril ou le dimanche 5 mai le deuxième
tour qui intervient quinze jours après
aurait donc lieu soit le dimanche 12 mai
soit le dimanche 19
si l'on se reporte à tout ce qui a été
dit ou écrit depuis quelques mois sur
une élection présidentielle à venir
quelle pourrait être la situation il
pourrait y avoir des candidatures de
principe à l'extrême gauche à l'extrême
droite ou à titre individuel par exemple
messieurs le pen et fouché ont déjà
depuis quelques temps manifesté le désir
de se présenter à une prochaine élection
présidentielle
arlette laguiller pour lutte ouvrière se
présentera il y aura ensuite les
candidats des grands courants politiques
pour la gauche le problème sera de
savoir si elle présentera dès le premier
tour un candidat unique
les communistes ont toujours donné
l'impression de le vouloir les
socialistes en particulier françois
mitterrand qui pourrait être ce candidat
unique ont paru plus réservés les
réformateurs eux ont pris récemment à
versailles la décision de principe
d'être présent si une élection
présidentielle intervenait
maintiendront-ils cette décision de
principe la majorité choisira-t-elle la
formule d'une élection primaire au
premier tour avec un candidat
républicain indépendant et un candidat
udf
est il besoin de rappeler que les deux
noms qui ont le plus souvent prononcées
sont ceux de monsieur giscard d'estaing
et chaban delmas
voilà donc les points d'interrogation il
est évident que dans les jours qui
viennent les partis politiques vont
siéger en permanence renonce déjà pour
dimanche
un comité central de lui des airs et
peut-être pour le week-end une
convention ou à congrès du parti
socialiste et demain un comité central 2
du parti communiste si l'élection
présidentielle a lieu le 28 avril les
candidatures doivent être devrait être
déposé au milieu de la semaine prochaine
mardi prochain avant minuit quel que
soit en réalité la brièveté des délais
qu'impose la constitution pour le dépôt
de ces candidatures
toutes les formations politiques ont
décidé de s'accorder ne serait ce que
par décence
un moment de réflexion et de silence
dans un instant
les autres nouvelles de l'actualité de
ce triste 3 avril vont être résumée mais
je voudrais vous indiqué auparavant que
l'autre journal sera immédiatement suivi
d'une émission spéciale de 24 heures sur
la une consacré au président pompidou le
portrait de l'homme d'abord puis au
travers de ses déclarations publiques
le message le testament politique qu'il
laisse mes entendu le décès du président
de la république a des incidences
importantes sur l'ensemble de
l'actualité tout d'abord le parlement
reste en session de printemps la
première séance avait eu lieu mardi mais
les députés ne voteront pas de loi tant
qu'un nouveau président ne sera pas élu
ainsi certains projets qui devaient être
votées vont être reportées par exemple
la loi sur l'interruption de grossesse
la loi font années de réformes
l'enseignement second
aussi la proposition d'augmenter le
pourcentage du second tiers provisionnel
les députés se réuniront demain 4 avril
à 15h30 mais ils n'entendront pas la
déclaration de politique générale que
devait faire le premier ministre elle a
été annulée
rappelons à ce propos que pendant la
vacance de la présidence
une motion de censure ne peut être
déposée et que le premier ministre ne
peut pas non plus poser la question de
confiance
c'est donc une période d'attentes sur le
plan de la politique pour l'économie il
en est de même en raison de la grève du
personnel de la bourse il n'y a pas eu
de cotation ce matin à paris il a donc
été impossible d'enregistrer les
réactions de l'industrie et des porteurs
de parts mais sur le marché des changes
on a noté un léger recul du franc
surtout une nouvelle hausse de l'or la
barre de 12 kilos et demi échangés entre
banca monte de 10% qu'autant 31 mille
francs
record absolu du fixing de l'or à paris
donc nouvelle précipitation vers cette
valeur refuge qu'est l'or une
précipitation que de nombreux
observateurs estiment exagère sur le
plan social il est probable que le
climat se détendent momentanément par
décence et pour éviter d'influer sur la
prochaine campagne électorale les
centrales ouvrières à l'exception
semble-t-il de la cfdt ont certainement
agir auprès des salariés leur demander
de cesser ou tout au moins d'atténuer
les mouvements de grèves actuel sans
pour autant abandonner les
revendications d'ores et déjà des
mouvements ont été supprimés les dockers
ne feront pas grève samedi comme il
l'avait prévu tout en maintenant leur
action pour l'amélioration des
conditions de travail des arrêts de
travail avaient commencé dans les débits
de boisson la confédération des
hôteliers-restaurateurs demande à ses
adhérents d'annuler signer dié leur
grève pour les 13 principaux conflits
les choses se présentent autrement mais
il semble qu'un effort général soit
entrepris pour mener à bien les
négociations en cours aux chantiers de
l'atlantique à saint nazaire par exemple
on a négocié toute la journée dans les
banques c'est toujours l'impasse mais il
ya eu quelques signes de reprise
aujourd'hui tandis qu'une négociation
pourrait s'engager à propos du paiement
des jours de grève
enfin il ya le cas du paquebot france
qui a jeté l'ancré très tôt ce matin
dans le port de cannes son pavillon en
berne en raison du décès du président de
la république
les marins ont adopté une résolution
selon laquelle il occuperait le paquebot
en quelque bord que ce soit si le
désarmement était soudain annoncé
voilà pour l'actualité d'aujourd'hui
brièvement résumé je vous rappelle donc
samedi sera journée de deuil national qu
aucun spectacle ne sera donné ce soir
déjà le gala de l'opéra est annulé et
demain les théâtres subventionnés comme
la comédie française et l'odéon feront
également relâche le sport continue à
l'exception de samedi où toutes les
rencontres seront annulés mais les huit
matches de coupe de france de football
ont commencé à 20h ce soir avec une
minute de silence
d'autre part je dois vous signaler qu'en
raison des circonstances
les organisateurs de la campagne vaincre
le cancer ont décidé en accord avec la
direction générale de la ftf de reporter
les appels à la générosité du public
dont les premiers ont été diffusés vous
le savez hier soir l'importance et la
nécessité de cette campagne demeurant
elle reprendra à partir du dimanche 7
avril sur nos antennes notre journal
s'achève notre émission spéciale
commence relayée par plusieurs
télévisions étrangères
deux parties tout à l'heure le message
de georges pompidou sa pensée politique
au travers de ses déclarations publiques
mais pour commencer un portrait de
georges pompidou président de la
république française
né le 5 juillet 1911 mort le 2 avril